now a person with bad breath is usually
the last person to know they have bad
breath how do we know that because
they're usually talking very close to
your face without too much awareness on
their bad breath i have some very uh
interesting information that you
probably haven't heard before that is
very very important especially related
to
breath you see just like in my other
videos if you want to know the truth
about health
just find out what everyone's
recommending and do the opposite or
finding out what they're telling you not
to do
and do it and this definitely applies to
bad breath so before i get into that
point i want to first talk about certain
foods that
can cause bad breath so you have garlic
onions both of those foods are loaded
with sulfur compounds so eating anything
with sulfur can definitely give you a
certain odor so if your spouse or
partner eats anything
with garlic or onions unless you're
eating things with garlic and onions
it's going to be pretty unpleasant and
then you have cheese there's all sorts
of stinky cheese limburger cheese for
example or blue cheese which has mold in
it will all contribute to some pretty
nasty breath but when you ask someone
like when i ask my father why do you eat
limburger cheese it smells so bad
apparently it doesn't taste bad it just
smells bad so i first want to talk about
some real simple things you can do to
counter your bad breath if you've eaten
foods with garlic onion
cheese etc one thing that works really
good to counter the bad breath is green
tea you can use it as a mouthwash you
can drink it it seems to counter the
sulfur compounds in certain foods now
the other thing that's really good
organic parsley and mint or peppermint
and then when you have garlic or onions
just take a little bit out of your
refrigerator and chew on it it
completely neutralizes the bad taste and
the smell that you would get from eating
those foods now
another type of toothpaste that i like
to recommend
especially if someone has bad breath is
toothpaste with clove and there's all
different combinations with with clove
with cardamom they're really really good
to even act as a natural
antibiotic without killing the good
bacteria now this leads me right into a
very important topic
that
so many people have no idea that's
creating a big problem with their breath
and that is using toothpaste with
fluoride and using a mouthwash with
alcohol you see there's something
that is either
not understood that's missing in the
area of oral health which is this in
your mouth you have hundreds of
different species of microbes growing
okay in your mouth and as far as a
quantity we're talking about hundreds of
billions of microbes now we want them
mostly friendly but you have two
different groups you have the unfriendly
ones and you have the friendly ones so
when you talk about fluoride in your
toothpaste right that kills the germs
that might cause plaque that can then
cause bad breath or when you're talking
about mouthwash that kills the germs
that cause bad breath what about the
good germs that prevent bad breath it's
not that you just have these bad germs
in your mouth that are causing bad
breath and then you can sterilize your
mouth and everything's better that's the
same logic is taking an antibiotic
thinking that you're killing off the
infection when you're in fact killing
off
all of the microbes that are supposed to
protect you against infections and this
reasoning has led to antibiotic
resistance a massive amount of
overgrowth of unfriendly
bacteria
and yeast and an overgrowth of candida
oral thrush or a white tongue where you
have too much unfriendly yeast that is
giving you some pretty bad breath so
fluoride
and chloride in your water combined as
you're brushing your teeth and getting
this water in your mouth is basically
killing both the good and bad bacteria
so it might give you a nice breath
initially but then it ends up being
bad breath so i would recommend getting
toothpaste without the fluoride i would
recommend also getting a water filter
and i would definitely avoid the
mouthwashes with alcohol because alcohol
kills microbes
i mean think about a sanitizer with
rubbing alcohol that's supposed to kill
viruses and bacteria what do you think
it's doing to your friendly bacteria now
there's some other things you can do as
well you can actually get some gum with
xylitol xylitol is a sugar alcohol
that is very selective in what it kills
off it won't kill off the good bacteria
it only apparently kills off certain bad
bacteria that cause plaque
the bad bacteria that causes plaque
apparently gives off a certain gas that
is kind of stinky so that would be one
thing you can do
another thing to do as a natural
deodorizer is to consume things with
chlorophyll
now what would that be that would be all
the green stuff in
plants as in vegetables okay i think one
of the best sources of chlorophyll would
be the wheatgrass juice powder that
stuff has some serious chlorophyll and
it's a great deodorizer not just for
your mouth but internally okay all the
organs including the intestine all right
the next point i want to bring up is
coffee and coffee breath
that can be quite nasty now that's
because the sulfur compounds in coffee
beans as well as certain acids that
occur in the coffee bean including
cannons which can
really dry out your mouth and affect
your the microbiome in your mouth so of
course with coffee breath you want to
brush your teeth with some really good
toothpaste that has clove and it doesn't
have fluoride but chewing parsley and
mint is also a really good thing all
right i already mentioned a little bit
about alcohol but it's not just the
alcohol mouthwash it's also the alcohol
in
alcohol
beverages so if you drink alcohol every
so often just make sure that you don't
consume
more than a six pack a night and you
want to take a natural probiotic and i'm
mainly talking about like fermented
vegetables and sauerkraut kimchi
things like that to reestablish these
microbes all right the next point i want
to bring up and this is probably the
number one source of that breath that
would be sugar sugar feeds unfriendly
microbes it feeds yeast
which is a type of candida and so that's
its primary fuel if you want to starve
off these unfriendly microbes
very simple just avoid sugar that's
called the ketogenic diet
so again these microbes
give off a smelly gas and they produce
bad breath they also make acids that can
put holes in your bones and i'm talking
about your teeth as in cavities and the
average teenager is consuming
at least
18 teaspoons of sugar and that's just
added that's not part of the normal
carbohydrates that they're consuming so
you can imagine how much
bad bacteria that's being generated now
the next point i want to bring up
is the fact that your mouth is part of
an entire system called the digestive
system so when you focus on one little
part of this whole system and neglect
the other parts you're not going to ever
fix bad breath so
many people have bad breath because of a
lower digestive system problem either in
the stomach the small intestine or the
large intestine so this is why if you
have weak stomach acid or you don't have
enough acidity in your stomach you're
not going to get the proper digestion
and that alone can create gas that can
come up for your breath and that occurs
from just having incomplete digestion
so this is why apple cider vinegar on a
regular basis
this is why taking betaine hydrochloride
after a meal which is a natural
acidifier is really good for bad breath
and also it prevents something called
sibo small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth
normally
the bacteria should be in the large
intestine not so much in the small
intestine i mean there's a little bit in
there but there shouldn't be a lot when
you get too much bacteria
and i'm even talking about the good
bacteria in the wrong place
you're going to have sibo and what
happens is these microbes compete for
your nutrients
and they also create a lot of gas and
they create a lot of bad breath in
overgrowth of unfriendly microbes and
this can definitely create not just
bloating
but it also can create some bad breath
now the thing you need to know about
this is that if you consume probiotics
and fiber okay and salads and you feel
worse you have a lot of distension
that could mean that you have sibo in
which case you should stop eating those
things and go carnivore for a little
while because
to kill these microbes you have to not
feed them anymore and you'd want to take
things like betaine hydrochloride and
you'd want to do fasting to allow the
digestive system to reset and you might
want to take a natural
antibiotic like oregano for example so
the reason i want to bring this up is
because the recommendation
of taking probiotics and fiber
might be conflicting if you have sibo so
one of the key ways you know
is with bloating and distension if you
have too much fiber or probiotics but
most of the population is going to
benefit
from probiotics and more vegetables and
things like that but if you don't then
suspect sibo but at this point probably
the most important thing to study next
is my video on digestion if you haven't
seen this i think you're going to really
like it check it out
you